- Hello Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe,
and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves,
and my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you,
you'll be able to go off
and change the planet.
Now, I started the Believe Love series,
because being in a
relationship can be hard
and being an entrepreneur can be hard.
And you combine both of
those two things together,
life gets a lot more difficult
and I thought it would be a great gift
for myself and Nina, for our relationship,
as well as for you guys to
every week explore new topics,
new ways to try to make
your relationships better.
So, today we're going to
learn from Jordan B. Peterson
on how to train your partner.
- You're having an
argument with your partner.
And you say, "You're a stupid person
"and you've always been a stupid person
"and, as far as I can tell,
"as far into the future as I can see,
"you're going to remain a stupid person."
So, what are they supposed to do?
What are they going to
do when you say that?
They're going to cry, like if you mean it.
They're going to get
angry, if you mean it.
And they're not going
to like you very much.
And why is that?
Well, it's like, it's assault, basically.
The only way really, the
only thing that you can do
in a situation like that
is walk away, ignore it,
respond in kind, or it
degenerates into violence.
That's it.
Because there's no discussion.
You haven't left the
person anywhere to go.
You've gone right to the
top of their hierarchy
and said everything about you is wrong,
and worse than that, all the mechanisms
that we could use to
correct it won't work.
So, those are fighting words.
So, don't do that, unless
you want to have a fight.
So then you might say, well
what would you do instead?
And the answer is deliver the least amount
of information you possibly can.
And so, let's say, you come home
and your person is watching TV
and you were kind of hoping
they'd greet you at the door.
You shouldn't break down into tears
and say, you're a stupid person.
You've always been a stupid person.
You're going to be a stupid
person in the future.
You should say, I have this peculiarity
and that is that, when I come home,
I don't have enough
confidence to just be happy.
I would like you to come and say,
just shut the TV off for two minutes,
come to the front door, and say hello
and then you can go
back and watch your TV.
Would it be okay, if you did that?
And they'll think, well, you'll
have to pay for it somehow.
But then they'll probably do it.
And so, but the thing is you've got
to specify the routine
that you want transformed
at the highest possible level
of resolution and you want
to recommend the minimal necessary change
that will satisfy you.
So you can't say, if you loved me,
you'd know how to greet me at the door.
Ha, not helpful, because they're stupid.
(audience laughs)
Right, and so are you!
So you have to spell it out.
It's like, what do you want?
Exactly, what would make you satisfied?
And then you have to
have your person, like,
grudgingly practice that a few times
and you have to let them do it very badly
and also in a bad temper and
then you have to reward them
for it and then, maybe three months later,
they'll do it properly.
So, you need to know that,
because that's what people are like.
It's very hard for them
to learn new things
and they're very resistant to it,
but they're very responsive to reward.
So, another thing,
this is partly what B.F.
Skinner figured out,
so when he was training
rats and he wanted a rat
to do something,
one of the things he would do is he put,
maybe he was going to train a
rat to climb a little ladder.
I mean, he could get rats to climb ladders
and then climb across, like,
the little monkey bars,
and then spin around three
times and then whack a ball
and then eat something.
Like, he got incredibly
complex behavior out of rats.
And the way he did that was patience.
So he put the ladder in the cage
and the rat would just run
around, doing rat things.
Then, it would put its
hand on the first rung
and Skinner would give it a pellet.
And so, he did it after.
Even once, the rat's
going to be like stand
in the immediate vicinity of the ladder
and then the frequency with
which it's going to go like this
has just increased.
So then he does it again.
Bang, pellet!
Well, soon, the rat is just
going like this, right?
So then, you wait until the
rat tries the other hand.
So you give it a pellet then.
Well, then it's going like this.
And then, because it's going to get bored,
it'll go like this.
It'll hit the next stair.
Bang, you give it a pellet.
Soon the rat's climbing
and doing all the little
things you want it to do.
Now, the problem with that
is you have to be patient.
You have to wait 'til the
rat does what you want.
Okay, that's more relationship advice.
(audience laughs)
Wait 'til the rat does what
you want and then reward it.
And it's unbelievably useful.
It's also extraordinarily positive.
I mean, I'm being, you know, comical,
in so far as I can manage
that, about this situation.
But people love reward
and they love attention.
People love attention
more than anything else.
And so, if you watch through the day
and when your partner does
something that's good,
say, man that was good,
or something like that.
You can be inventive.
And then they'll do it more.
And if you do that a whole
bunch, like for a year,
they'll be doing things
that are good for you,
just all the time.
But you have to be patient,
which is very annoying,
and you have to suppress
your response to only respond
to negative things.
You know, because what we know
about the expectancy
models is that a deviation
from expectation produces a
burst of negative emotions.
You know, so you come home
and the whole house is clean,
but there's, like, I don't
know, the dog has shed
on the rug or something and
the person overlooked that.
It's not like you're going
to see the clean house,
you're going to see the
rug with the dog fur on it.
You're going to say, why
didn't you clean up the rug
with the dog fur?
And they're going to
say, good luck getting me
to clean up the house again.
And, you know, because the thing
is the exception stands out
and what's done doesn't,
and the reason for that is you
can just ignore what's done,
because it's done.
It doesn't get in your way.
So, it gets invisible really quickly.
So, you really got to watch that tendency.
One of the things Nietzsche said was that,
if you really want to punish someone,
you don't punish them when
they do something wrong,
because they expect that.
That's not a punishment!
They expect that!
They might even be relieved by it.
You want to punish them when
they do something right,
because then you'll really hurt them.
And so, that's something to think about,
if you're in a relationship, man.
If someone's done something
right, do not punish them.
You do that two or three times, that's it.
You're not going to get
them to do that anymore.
So, judiciousness.
Watch what they're doing.
If something happens
that's good, notice it.
And, you know, if they've
done a bunch of things,
don't concentrate on the
things they did wrong.
That's not smart.
It's really hard on them too.
In some sense, this sounds
manipulative and selfish,
because I'm teaching you
how to train your partner.
(audience laughs)
But you should also teach
them how to train you.
Because it would be really nice,
if you could come home
and the person would say,
What did you do today?
And you say, here's a bunch
of things I did and they say,
well, this looks really
good and that was great,
and why don't you do some more of that?
And you're like, oh boy!
(audience laughs)
It was a great day!
And so, you know, you can train
them to train you properly.
And that's a really helpful thing,
especially if you do it over a few years.
You know, that's how you
have a good relationship,
because you're both clueless
as hell to begin with.
(audience laughs)
You don't know even what
would make you happy,
much less what would make
the other person happy.
And so, you've got to figure
these things out bit by bit
and then you have to inform each other
and then you have to be patient enough
to let your partner do
these things really badly.
I'll give you another example.
Sometimes, I see couples sporadically
in my clinical practice.
I'm not a couples counselor.
And so, but sometimes, when
I'm working with someone,
there's an issue that
needs to be discussed
with both people, because,
otherwise, it's just stupid.
And one of the things I
often recommend to people,
especially once they have
kids, is that they set aside,
to use an anachronistic
phrase, date nights.
Well, everyone hates that idea.
It's like they say, well,
you know, they'll just say,
I'm not doing that.
That would be one objection.
We're just not doing that.
You know, that's what we
did before we got married.
They'll say, well, my partner
would never go for that.
They've got a bunch of excuses
why that isn't going to work.
And so, I've heard all those excuses.
I know all of them.
And then maybe I convince them.
Yeah, yeah, sure, I know, this is stupid.
It's awkward, it's artificial.
That's okay, just try it once.
So then, they go and try
it, and then they come back
and they say, we had an
absolutely miserable time.
Really, we had a miserable time.
We couldn't agree on what
movie to go to and then,
she took me to her movie
and I really didn't like it.
So, we fought all the way home.
We're never doing that again.
And I say, wow, really,
you've got 30 years, 400 days.
That's 12,000 days.
Okay, so, you're not going to do that.
You're going to spend the next 12,000 days
without having any real romantic
evenings and interactions
with your spouse.
That's your plan?
(audience laughs)
I like doing arithmetic with my clients.
They hate that.
(audience laughs)
They hate arithmetic.
It's like, well no, that
sounds like a bad idea.
I said, okay, well, would you
like some romance in your life
or are you just done with that?
(audience laughs)
Now, really, people can go for a long time
with no romance at all.
Say well, no, maybe
we'd like some of that.
Well, how much?
Once a year.
Well, no.
Once a month?
Once every two weeks?
Well, sometimes people are really busy.
It's like that beats the hell out of zero.
Once a week?
Twice a week?
Okay, whatever, we're going
to start with a range, okay.
What would a good evening look like?
Like, if you could both get
exactly what you wanted,
what would it look like?
Well, then they have to think about that,
because the previous theory was,
my stupid partner should know what I like,
and that's what the
partner is thinking too.
It's like good luck with that,
because, no, they don't have a clue,
especially if they're men.
They don't have a clue.
(audience laughs)
So you have to tell them what you want
and how they could
deliver it and vice versa,
which is very awkward and horrible.
And then you have to
practice it for six months,
because, you know, it
takes a lot of practice
to do something sophisticated really well.
And then if you do that, it's like, poof!
You got it for the rest of your life.
So, it's worth the aggravation.
You know when the first
time the rat puts its paw
up on the ladder, it's just
sort of doing it accidentally.
You can't expect it to do it well.
And that's exactly how
to view your own progress
and the progress of your partner.
It's like let them do
it badly for a while.
At least, they're doing it.
So if you think you should do it faster,
well, look real hard
and see how easy it is
to change your own behavior,
because it's really hard to
change your own behavior.
Everybody says, I'm going to
exercise three times a week!
(audience laughs)
At New Year's, and it's like no one does.
They buy the memberships
and then they feel guilty
for having it, but they
don't actually go to the gym.
And that's a perfect example
of how difficult it is
to transform behavior.
- Thank you guys so much for watching!
I'd love to know what did you think,
what did you take from this
video that you are going
to apply somehow to your relationships.
Should we continue this series or not?
It's still a new one for us
and it's kind of on the bubble.
I'd like it to, but you guys
ultimately get to decide.
Let me know, leave it down
in the comments below.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
See you soon.